foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Draco malfoyslaki's Vincent
crab and Gregory Goyle we first see
these two goons pop up right near the
beginning of the Harry Potter story
standing there dim waited as ever behind
their gang leader Draco while many
friendships blossomed within the walls
of Hogwarts particularly in the first
few years it seems as though both crab
and Goyle were friends with Draco before
their Hogwarts days a fact that I'm sure
can be attributed to their ties in the
pure-blooded Wizard Community grab and
Goyle proud Sutherlands certainly made
the lives of many Hogwarts students
miserable during their time at the
school with Draco at the helm of their
gang they even made a special point of
making it their absolute priority to
bully the famous Trio Harry Ron and
Hermione and in their later years just a
year or two shy from Hogwarts situation
they took things a step further
transcending the title of traditional
bully and instead becoming what could
only be aptly described as full-blown
criminals but one thing I've always
wondered is whether or not Vincent Crabb
and Gregory Goyle were teenage Death
Eaters just like their leader Draco
Malfoy was but they brought into the
cool like so many of the dark Wizards in
The Wizarding World or was there
salvation for these two boys to some the
answer to this question may be obvious
of course krabencoil were Death Eaters
how could they avoid it it was an
Outlander but here's the thing it's
never explicitly stated in Canon and
there may just be a reason for that the
first thing no one to address is their
parentage and here Voldemort moved on to
the two largest hooded figures we have
crab you will do better this time will
you not crab and you Goyle they bowed
clumsily much answering totally Yes
master we will Master with Voldemort's
Resurgence in the Goblet of Fire or
proper one anyway he summons the Death
Eaters by way of the dark mark and what
I found interesting about this is that
seemingly Elder krabengoyle krabengo's
fathers were too tight at the hip
blistering buffoons just like their sons
they too were clumsy awkwardly large and
incompetent like father like son I guess
so if krabenco's fathers were so very
much like them then this could suggest
that they too went down the very same
dark path bearing the infamous dark mark
on their arms and serving the tyrannical
leader of the Death Eaters that is Lord
Voldemort it stands to reason that if
crab and gold Jr was so very much like
their fathers then they would want to
emulate the actions and behaviors of
their fathers further by going down the
same dark path they this is also
consistent with the Trope repeated again
and again in Harry Potter where children
end up closely modeling their parents in
a multitude of ways in looks interests
Behavior
Etc but still this is not an answer it's
just an inference an argument for why
they could have been Death Eaters let's
dig in further as the books progress I
think it becomes more and more obvious
that crab and Goyle have evolved into a
new type of bully one less focused on
ridiculing their victims and more
focused on causing them harm this is
glaringly apparent on a few occasions
one of the first being when Harry gets
word that the carrots were teaching Dark
Arts at Hogwarts Amicus the bloke he
teaches what used to be defense against
the dark arts except now it's just the
dark arts we're supposed to practice the
cruciatus curse on people who've earned
attentions what Harry Ron and Hermione's
United voices echoed up and down the
passage
we're supposed to practice the
cruciata's curse on people who've earned
attentions I refuse to do it some people
are into it though crab and Goyle love
it the first time they've ever been
topping anything I expect in my eyes the
fact that crab and Goyle were more than
willing to torture their classmates is a
testament to the type of people they've
become if it was never mentioned that
they loved it then I suppose we could
assume that they were acting out of fear
but this is clearly not the case Harry
Potter after crucio was first cast on
him described as feeling like his head
was being split open while having his
bones set on fire this is not something
that any good person would wish upon
anyone and it's particularly horrifying
if we consider the fact that they were
doing this to their fellow students
people that they had known for years the
next passage that I want to look at
comes from the Deathly Hallows
specifically chapter 31 the Battle of
Hogwarts so how come you three aren't
with Voldemort asked Harry we're going
to be rewarded said Crabb his voice was
surprisingly soft for such an enormous
person Harry had hardly ever heard him
speak before crab was smiling like a
small child promised a large bag of
sweets the young back Potter we decided
not to go decided to bring you to him
good plan said Harry and mock admiration
he could not believe that he was this
close and was going to be thwarted by
Malfoy crab and coil this passage makes
it undeniably clear that krabengoyle or
just crab at the very least was willing
to physically harm Harry and essentially
facilitate Harry's death by handing him
off to Voldemort crab the more talented
of the two also fires multiple lethal
curses at Harry and Co it was not normal
fire crab had used occurs of which Harry
had no knowledge as they turned a corner
the Flames chased them as though they
were alive sentient intent upon killing
them now the fire was mutating forming a
gigantic pack of fiery beasts flaming
serpents chimeras and Dragons Rose and
fell and rose again and to the detritus
of centuries in which they were feeding
was thrown up in the air into their
fanged mouths tossed high on clawed feet
before being consumed by The Inferno
crab wheeled round and screamed Avada
cadaver again Ron leapt out of sight to
avoid the jet of green light the
wonderless Malfoy coward behind a
three-legged wardrobe as Hermione
charged towards them hitting Goyle with
a stunning spell as she came provided
that krabengirl were willing to go to
Such Great Lengths to appease Lord
Voldemort then I think the logical
explanation would be that yes these two
boys weren't Death Eaters but still
after all that they did I find myself
entirely unconvinced why because
kravengoyle was still blithering idiots
and Voldemort knew perfectly how to use
and manipulate people to him crap and
Goyle were disposable pawns
sacrifices that he could send in without
even an ounce of hesitation can you
imagine Voldemort in a direct line of
communication with Vincent Crabb or
Gregory Goyle at the end of the day in
my view grab and Goyle was simply
wannabe Death Eaters young misguided
boys that tried to follow in their
Father's Footsteps impressionable
sympathizers that just wanted to get in
on a bit of the action yes Krav magor's
fathers were Death Eaters but Voldemort
wouldn't devote them anything
particularly after failing him in the
first Wizarding war and never making any
kind of proper attempt to find him as
far as teenage Death Eaters go Draco was
the only one and that's only because
he'd been given a special task however
hadvoldemort not wanted to punish Lucius
I don't think Draco would have become a
Death Eater either
Voldemort always intended for Draco to
die during his attempts to kill
Dumbledore and it cost him absolutely
nothing to dangle glory and acceptance
in draco's face after giving him a
seemingly impossible task a task that he
himself would have failed the sad truth
is that neither crab nor Goyle ever
stood a chance they both came from a
family of Death Eaters and right from
the start became part of a friend group
that made all the wrong choices to quote
Dumbledore it is our choices Harry that
show what we truly are far more than our
abilities and unfortunately crab and
Goyle with poor influences and obvious
mental disadvantages weren't ever able
to make the right choices and that's it
for this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel do you think that crab and
goel were Death Eaters leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live